when we had mcnabb on here i didn't know
15 years later that you guys
are not reconciled no i've tried he's
phony i tried to be cordial with the
situation i thought we had squashed it
but then you guys did an interview and
then
all this surf it resurfaces again
so who we got in the pool hall today
finally t-o
what's happening let's go with you man
i'm good bro how you living just like
everybody else doing this pandemic slow
right now
i gotta ask you man how nice you on the
pool table because the up toe stories
audience has been waiting for you to
jump on the pool table well you know i
can't
really come here to play no pool but you
know don't worry
audience getting that popcorn ready too
okay so i got to ask you untold stories
audience have been waiting for you to
jump on this show right
after the diamond mcnabb episode what
was your reaction when you saw that
episode i mean just listening to some of
the comments and statements about
i pretty much ruined the opportunity to
run it back
leading up to the super bowl all the
questions within the media they were
geared around
was i going to make it back for him to
be really the quarterback the face of
the franchise
i felt like he could have answered those
questions i guess
for whatever reason the statement of or
he didn't need me to win the super bowl
or play in the super bowl
i felt that was a slight for whatever
reason and then i saw the interview
like it's unbelievable but you know that
was something that
kind of broke us up that was the most
frustrating for me because i knew
what we could do and if we decided to
just come together
what we'd be able to accomplish he said
that i ruined their chances so for me it
was contradictory
to say that you didn't need me to play
in the super bowl and win it
but then i prevented you guys from
running it back
so you didn't need me then so why would
you need me to run it back for me i felt
like it was
bush league to me to be honest
you out here playing bumper pool the old
four season
we heard mcnabb's perspective in terms
of how he felt that season played out
i want to hear your perspective how did
you feel the 04 season started when i
went over to the
philadelphia eagles i had nothing but
the utmost respect for
that organization and for me to come
over and add to the firepower that they
already had with donovan at the
quarterback position
in san francisco i didn't have a
quarterback that could step back you
know throw the ball
you know 80 90 yards down the field we
had that endowment i knew that going
over there
70 yard drop in the bucket right yeah i
mean 81 yards right on the jersey number
yeah right right on the jersey number so
04 season started smooth then oh man it
started out with a banger
going throughout the course of the
season there was no problems there were
no problems the the city of philadelphia
embraced me
where i was at the height of my career
at that time i felt like i was
unstoppable i knew what i brought to the
table
everything was going according to
playing and then late december
we playing the cowboys and uh that's
cowboys fan man so that play
it's nev i can never forget that play
that yeah that play there i mean it
changed a lot of things for
really kind of the rest of the season
for us and you know for the league that
played by roy williams it got deemed as
the horse color rule so how long the
time are you supposed to be out for with
that type of injury
for any normal person they're done for
the rest of the season
i took that as a challenge and i was
like okay cool let's let's get with it
and i vowed at that time i said if our
team play in these playoffs and they win
i said i will be i'll be ready for the
super bowl
i'll be ready that's what i and i truly
believe that how'd you perform how did
you feel you did
i didn't do bad you know considering
what were the stats again
nine for 122 nine for 122. what happened
against the patriots when you a
quarterback or any other position
uh do what got you there you know try
not to do too much
i was trying to be perfect and so some
of the balls that
which i threw obviously ended up being
intercepted and turnovers versus new
england
it's tough because they always come back
and capitalize there were some things
that were said and known
after the fact about you know donovan's
play things of that nature
like what i mean they said he threw up
in the huddle i need you to set the
record straight
then i did
where did this come from you know what
it's that's a that's a great question
as i say every time people bring it up
roll the videotape
you know the film don't lie why would
somebody lie there were teammates
that said he threw up in the huddle
personally i didn't see it
but there are guys and i know that there
are teammates that i've talked to
recently
that said that they saw him throw up in
the huddle i've talked to teammates
since then
and know for a fact that he was out the
night before he was out the night before
yeah he was out the night before before
the biggest game pretty much of all of
our careers there's people that
saw him out the night before said he was
drinking and i think that attributed to
him throwing up in the huddle he's
obviously had a history of condition
problems so for me
you know knowing all this information i
felt like that was irresponsible
especially for somebody of his caliber
his status to obviously be the leader of
the team
and you're out night before the biggest
game of your career you're out drinking
or what have you
and then that maybe contributed to him
throwing up in the huddle it's just
not good money just don't scratch yeah
yeah
at this point you guys still cool like
when did things turn
that this one between you and mcnabb at
this point like i had
no problems with mcnabb i think things
turned sour the next year
obviously there are some contract
negotiations some situations
surrounding me andy reid and i we had
some disagreements
he sent me home for the day he basically
just told me to keep myself in shape you
know he'll get back and touch me when he
feels like we're ready to resume or
whatever and all of a sudden there's
turmoil here and there conversation
going back and forth
and we had to answer those questions
instead of
focusing on what we need to do in order
to get back to where we were what ends
up coming out of that so i go home
i drive home by the time i get home
obviously it's it's breaking news
it's basically hit the media wire that
i've been sent home
or what have you and i'm in the house
maybe 20 30 minutes
the next thing you know i hear a knock
at the door i look through the blinds
and meteor trucks are camped in my in my
front yard what's going on your mind
that's not a normal experience man even
an athlete like that's not enormous no
it wasn't normal for me
like i said i it was very unexpected i
just didn't
understand what the hoopla was i guess
surrounding me i learned to embrace it
and i think that moment was
me learning and trying to embrace the
media so that's why
i came out there with the ad bench and
doing the sit-ups and things of that
nature
because i tried to make light of a
situation i took it to heart
that andy reid said he told me to stay
in shape while i was away
so i just took it literally yeah i
literally i did i
took it that way i thought that was the
major distraction for us
you know he's doing sit-ups you know
he's doing push-ups he's playing
basketball he ordered pizza for the
people out there
and we sitting there at training camp
just like you gotta be kidding me
honestly if you look in that clip i got
a
earpiece in my ear i had my publicist on
the line
and she's hearing everything that's
going on and so she's hearing the
questions and she's basically telling me
what to say
so but i mean it was just me having fun
with that moment we're in our dorm rooms
and you know i'm just sitting there and
i'm watching on tv
and brian dawkins and trotter with my
roommate and dog could come and he was
like man what do you do now i'm like
take a look like this is like
days of our lives looking back on that
do you wish you could have handled that
differently or like oh i mean
if it happened today i would probably do
the same thing you know i mean
i may have added some popcorn and some
some a little bit of everything at this
point in time like i really would have
made it
really a show speaking of popcorn can i
get some popcorn
i got you i hope you all got your
popcorn ready yeah yeah you gotta have
your popcorn i gotta have a pound
of time yeah no doubt at that time that
was between
me and andy reid it was a disagreement
he sent me home
what i do at my house is my business i
don't worry about what you're doing in
your house
at this point too so you're going
through the contract situation you
mentioned earlier about mcnabb
what was his involvement in terms of
your contract situation what did you
hope that he would do
donovan he was an advocate for brian
restbrook getting his money
when it came to me he wasn't as vocal
you don't talk about another man's
pocket you know what i mean you don't
talk about another man's money
but at the end of the day he took the
liberty to talk about and be an advocate
for brian's contract
but then when it came to me it was a
polar opposite so that's why i knew
things that kind of changed what do you
think that was
no no you should have asked him for
whatever reason i guess it it ate at
him that people said that i made him a
better quarterback those were questions
that the media had asked him
and he snapped back at him be
complimentary
at that point is that when the fallout's
just so evident yeah i mean i think from
that point even from the super bowl with
him answering the questions of
he didn't need me to win the super bowl
when we had mcnabb on here i didn't know
15 years later that you guys are not
reconciled no i've tried
i tried to be cordial with the situation
i thought we had squashed it but then
you guys did an interview
last year whenever it was some months
ago and then all this
resurfaces again you and t on talking
terms what's the relationship like now
hey i give a nice peace sign and keep it
moving you know however
you know i respect his time you know i
love my time
you know and there's no need for me to
try to dust off anything that happened
in the past because what was in the past
is in the past
you know he's made a few comments you
know as of late
that's cool with me listen i'm a grown
man i had a grown man business
will it ever be a point of
reconciliation you think i heard it 15
years 20 years
say he's moved on and he put something
bro at the end of the day he don't make
me man
like i said i'm in the hall of fame for
what i've done and what i've
accomplished
i appreciate the opportunity i played
with him but at the end of the day like
i said check my stats before i got there
and check my stats when i left he's
supposed to be the great quarterback or
one of the top quarterbacks in the
league
in his mind you can't go to washington
and not beat out rex grossman
you think he belongs in the whole time i
could care less
at the end of the day i'm worried about
me i could care less about that
i tried a lot of heat on that one yeah i
tried to bring some sauce with that
[Music]
thing